what are some of those little techniques
just a few if you can that make us care
about so for character and I talked
about this in my Pixar seminar so
because they masters of this you know
they tell stories about toys about
monsters about bugs about robots right
you know fish rat
they make you care and connect with
those characters so there's there's a
whole bunch of techniques and and you
can see what they do and you can know
what the techniques are for me it's like
there's three three things that you do
that I that you do is is make us make us
feel sorry for that character so there's
a little moments where you can you can
create a moment in the story where a
character is unjustly abused or unjustly
mistreated or insulted or betrayed or
neglected and so it could be any
character and if that moment is there
you know feel sorry for that character
at that moment takes an instant so
that's one if you show that they're like
us if you show their humanity for
example you show that they care about
something other than themselves that's
another technique so there's a moment in
the movie Leon the professional which is
about a hitman right and it opens with
him doing a hit and he kills people you
don't know if he's good or bad but he
goes home and he takes care of a plant
right and that by the way you say oh no
he cares about a plant so he's okay he's
human the other part is admiration so
this is like any any kind of you know if
you're dating somebody or you're trying
to find somebody who's a good match for
you there's that list of lists of things
that you like in a person that's
admirable trait so somebody was funny
who's responsible who's courageous
there's a whole list of things you can
add to a character to make a say oh you
know I admire this usually they're like
the best at what they do they're like
the best you know the best at executive
or the best agent the best cop the best
they're courageous there's a whole bunch
of them I have hope the list the list is
all in the book there's all these lists
of things you can do but if you do these
three things and I so when I show clips
of the of the moment you meet the
character and usually like a
three-minute scene you can see all these
things being applied in like three
minutes there's like you know the the
opening of wall-e after he's done with
the garbage in comes to us to his little
house it's a three minute scene and it's
about 20 of these techniques done this
is how you connect with that character
in one scene emotionally I also show a
clip of a of an ad the commercials one
minute thing about a lamp whether it's
it's a great ad for IKEA award-winning
commercial where they make you carry
mostly for the lamp right and and the
joke about is that the guy comes and
says you know you probably had feelings
for these lamps that bit that's because
you're crazy the lamp has it's only a
lamp it's you know and the new one is
better you know the new lamp to replace
it so but anyway but it's great it's
amazing once you once you know those
techniques and then you see him in
action you got my conned you know and
now and I kind of always feel I was give
this caveat with to my students and to
anybody who hears me speak that if you
love stories if you love films and you
don't want me to destroy the illusion do
not listen to me because I feel like I'm
one of the magicians who would give you
the trick of how it's done and you then
you see the trick and it's not the same
anymore so I always feel bad about that
because you know once you know the
techniques and you see a film you're
gonna see them everywhere all the time
and it's gonna kind of ruin it for you
so just fair warning right there that
you know those are those are this is how
we do it and that creates that effect
you know
you